The capybara's open-air bath was the result of a coincidence.
One morning in 1982, when Quinn, the capybara's pet, was
cleaning the capybara with hot water,
capybaras gathered together in the bath, and when she poured hot water on them and
put their butts on them, they made such a gesture.
It struck me that maybe I should build a bath,
and everything changed from there.
[Music] prefecture
becauseThisIsThe
Birth
PLACE is cleaning  We
take a rest and look at the capybaras, check the temperature of the hot water,
and check on their health.In the
wild, capybaras live near water to protect themselves from predators,
so they prefer water.
It's a way for them to relax. I
think they are really enjoying the comfort of winter. A family of 12th-grade capybaras lives in the capybara open-air bath.
Fuma is the
father of all of them and has a very kind personality.
Yado Unzen Shinyu
[Music]
It's fun and fun to work at. Capybaras are very popular at the zoo and are
like idols. Well, the capybara
's hot springs are very famous and my daughter was born there, so I
want to show her to them.  That's why I came here.I
like that relaxed and cute expression.I feel
like it's
soothing.I like how she takes a bath like this.It's funny and cute, and I like
it because it makes the viewer feel excited.
Capybaras are active and calm.
People come to the soaping competitions and watermelonEating competitions that drawhuge [music] crowds.The reason customers watch capybara outdoor blogs
is because there is something we can all relate to.  Some of the
customers watch the time, and others
say that the sight of them bathing in an open-air bath is soothing.It makes the
people who look at it feel like they're reading a book, or something like that,
so that's why everyone comes here.DET